Speaker 1: I have a little old fashioned cringe
for you. Radical and repugnant. Reactionary
Republican Congresswoman Lauren Boebert
is very concerned about public urination,
but so much so that she ended up
making a complete and total fool
of herself during a recent hearing.
There's a little write up in Rolling
Stone about this. Lauren Boebert Obsesses
Over Public Urination at Crime Hearing.
Lauren Boebert waylaid a congressional
hearing on crime in Washington, D.C.,
by grilling D.C. City Council member Charles Allen
on what she insisted were efforts to decriminalize
public urination. It turns out that he didn't
actually do that. You have to see this clip.
This is unbelievable. And the guy is increasingly
visibly confused because he doesn't know what the
hell she's talking about. Check this out.
Speaker 4: And these charges. These changes
are now law here in D.C., Correct?
Speaker 3: Do you mean the revised
Criminal code? Yes. No, Those are not the law.
Speaker 1: Okay. First question was this
is now the law? Answer It is not the law.
Speaker 4: Not the law did with the overturn.
Speaker 3: Revised. Overturned. Was rejected by.
Speaker 4: Excuse me, Mr. Chairman. I'll talk to
Mr. Allen. Mr. Allen. Did you or did you not
decriminalize public urination in Washington,
D.C.? Did you lead the charge to do so?
Speaker 3: No. It the revised Criminal Code
left that as a criminal charge.
Speaker 4: Did you.
Speaker 1: Pseudonymous. But she keeps.
Speaker 4: Going. The charge to decriminalize
public urination in Washington, DC?
Speaker 3: No, ma'am.
Speaker 4: Did you ever vote in favor
of decriminalizing public urination in
Washington, DC.
Speaker 3: The
revised Criminal Code?
Speaker 4: Did you ever support.
Speaker 3: It as a criminal offense?
Speaker 4: Did you. Did you support this criminal?
Speaker 3: I voted for it. Yeah. You
voted. Oh, God, this is going so wrong.
Speaker 1: And it's absolutely delightful.
Speaker 4: To keep it as a criminal offense.
Speaker 3: That's correct.
Speaker 1: Wait, so you're telling me
you never advocated to make public urination? Not
a crime. You never voted to make it not a crime,
and you voted to keep it a crime? Yes.
Hmm. Interesting that now now, I'm not sure
Congress is devolving rapidly. You know,
I think we as a community of the left,
we expected that when Republicans took over
the House of Representatives, it would become a
circus sideshow. I think we expected that. But the
degree to which it has become a circus sideshow
is genuinely surprising even to me. And I've been
I've been doing this, you know, quite a long time.
After the fourth time, she brings up
public urination. I probably would have
lost it if I was in that room. And it is
just stunning. And the takeaway here is,
well, I don't know what the take away here is.
If Lauren Boebert is thinking about urinating in
public, which I guess is a concern for her, it
is still a crime. These people are genuinely a
joke. And we laugh to to a certain degree to avoid
crying. But I get emails from European viewers all
the time. In fact, let me see if I can pull one
up. I'm not even sure. You're I'm not even sure
how I'm going to be able to do this. Anyway, I
get so many emails from people saying, David,
what is happening in your country? Here's just
one as an example. I'm going to just read this. I
don't want to put the person I didn't blank it out
from the Netherlands. Someone wrote in and said,
David, I am encouraging you on your quest to
educate people in the United States. What on earth
is going on? Your thoughts and visions are clearly
needed in the United States. It is a crisis. What
is wrong with so many Americans? I was brought up
with the United States as a role model. Now, the
United States is a joke. Barely anything positive
is connected to the United States, particularly
because of the Republican Party. We increasingly
see the USA negatively because of these lunatics.
I understand that this is not your movement, but
it is a direct result of the populist rhetoric
that you criticize being misused by the Republican
Party and these complete and total clowns. Most
people here did like Barack Obama, but Trump
was ridiculed, and now it seems as though there
is no turning back. This is just an example.
Okay. That's Rinde from from the Netherlands,
from Amsterdam. Every single day we are a global
laughing stock. And it's not just anecdotally,
it's reflected in public opinion polls about how
people see the United States and how people see
the office of the presidency. We've got to do
something to turn it around. And another four
years of Trump isn't going to turn it around. And
certainly four years of Ron DeSantis won't either.